hey it's me i'm just excited to be
myself and talk and be unfiltered and
yeah it's fun well meghan markle's
recent unfiltered confessions aren't so
fun for the royal family a source tells
e.t they're disappointed by megan's
comments to the cut and on her
archetypes podcast i think it's the case
that megan
certainly feels that she was um
silenced to a degree she has spoken
about
being able to use her voice now which i
think suggests that as a member as a
working member of the royal family and
she felt at times restricted it all
started with megan's conversation in the
cuts fall fashion issue revealing she's
still healing from her traumatic
experience as a member of the royal
family after marrying prince harry quote
my entire job was tell me where to stand
tell me what to say tell me how to say
it tell me what to wear and i'll do it
when she married into the royal family
she essentially lost her voice she lost
her platform megan also addressed the
strained relationships both she and
prince harry have with their respective
fathers blaming taboi culture for
tearing their families apart she says
harry said to me i lost my dad in this
process it doesn't have to be the same
for them as it was for me but that's his
decision
a source close to prince charles shared
with e.t that he was saddened over that
comment the source adding the prince of
wales loves both his sons but megan
later clarified she was never referring
to harry's relationship with prince
charles she was only talking about her
relationship with her dad
i do know that charles absolutely wants
to start healing that fractured
relationship with harry i was told by a
source very close to him that he loves
his son that he will forgive his son for
everything and that he wants to repair
that relationship and move on on top of
that there's megan's podcast where she
shared how her blackness became more of
a focus when she and harry first linked
up if there's any time in my life that
it's been more focused on my race it's
only once i started dating my husband
then i started to understand what it was
like to be treated like a black woman
because up until then i had been treated
like a mixed woman
and things really shifted our source
says the royal family feels distressed
that after stepping back from her royal
duties claiming a need for privacy megan
continues to publicize family matters
simply put the source says the royals
feel a loss of trust with megan people
should expect the real me in this and
probably the me that they've never
gotten to know certainly not in the past
few years
where everything is through the lens of
the media
[Music]